this is not the first outbreak of bird
flu in the US and it won't be the last
what is the distinction of this current
wave we have had outbreaks of avian
influenza and thank you very much for
having me on the program we have had
outbreaks of influenza in the United
States and the know most notable one
that we had was back in Pennsylvania in
83 84 where we lost 17 million birds
with a cost of 60 million dollars and
since that time we've had smaller
outbreaks but this particular outbreak
has affected many states and many types
of birds across the United States so it
is a unimpressive outbreak in the United
States of bird flu
eight million birds have died in this
wave that's an incredible to me that's
an incredible number I mean how many
birds are there well it is an incredible
number but if we look at the poultry
industry in general we raised nine
billion broiler birds so those are the
chicken the meat type chickens that we
raise we raise over 200,000 and we also
raise a large amount of the layer birds
too in Pennsylvania alone we have 24
million layers in in Pennsylvania so
this is a very very large industry in
the United States and the risk to humans
according to the CDC is that it is low
but infection is possible which raises
more questions than really it answers
previous strains we know in other
countries in the past have been spread
to humans and people have died what
confidence you have this time around
that human infection and transmission
will remain low or non-existent well
this particular virus has been out in
other parts of the world and it hasn't
caused human infection so we always
watch that in CDC and the USDA always
watch those viruses because these
viruses can mutate and so we always want
to watch that carefully right now the
risk is very very low and we're watching
that but historically this virus
throughout the world really hasn't
caused any human infection so what's the
prescription for farmers I mean is there
a set of regulations farmers can follow
to stop the spread
or reduce the risk of the spread of
infection yet the important thing is
biosecurity and I'm sure you've heard
that that comment what is biosecurity it
really is reducing the risk of that
coming on to your farm so when we go on
farms for example when I go onto a farm
my vehicle is cleaned inside outside
clean clothes take a shower when I get
to the facility we put on boots hats
coveralls we step through disinfectant
baths but beyond that we have to look at
what all is coming on to the farm
various trucks come on to the farm
various people come on to the farm they
all have to come on in a bio-secure
manner and we have to if they're
non-essential people coming on the front
they shouldn't be on that farm so every
time something comes into that farm
that's a potential introduction but in
the big scheme what we need to do with
control we have to euthanize the birds
that are affected and then we have to
clean and disinfect that farm and then
that farm has to sit with no birds in it
for a very long time period so we can
get this outbreak under control sure we
know for a fact how the how this strain
of bird flu is being spread right now
well if we start back how it came into
the country we believe wild birds
carried that and many times the ducks
and the geese they'll carry it but they
won't have any disease so they'll be
perfectly fine but it's their droppings
that will have the virus in there and
then it can spread and then again
biosecurity it's important that we make
sure that it doesn't get spread from
farm to farm people dragging it into
poultry houses and that's the key here
is really looking at the biosecurity and
making sure we really put that barrier
so people don't get on to the farm and
we we stopped at that spread you
mentioned the last big epidemic which
was in 1983-84 in Pennsylvania it has
not reached the Atlantic Flyway this
time around does a windy spring change
all of that
well the question about wind has come up
before and the wind will not carry this
virus miles it could carry it on a farm
locally and actually could carry it
a farm that was close by and we had an
experience in one of the outbreaks not
the 83-84 outbreak but we had an
experience in another outbreak where it
was a very windy spring and we had an
affected farm and then the next farm
downwind got it and we knew by mapping
the prevailing winds that another farm
would get it and the producer actually
put plastic all along the side of his
house to stop the spread and it did but
I have to put a caveat in there we
actually at that point in time were
euthanizing the birds outside of the
house so the wind was carrying the
feathers and dander and everything
downwind and we don't do that anymore
so it's important when we do euthanize
these birds that they stay within the
house for you for us to depopulate and
euthanize in in that particular house
and not outside